[Applaudissements]
la tels que vous voyez à l'instant où je
vous parle
je suis engagé dans une aventure
à côté de laquelle mes deux tours du
monde en solitaire me paraissent me
paraîtrait presque facile quoique si je
compare avec mon premier vendée globe
l'aventuré beaucoup moins risqué
pas de tempête à redouter pas de
naufrage pas de chavirage mais c'est
beaucoup plus long ça fait bientôt
quatre ans que j'ai franchi la ligne de
départ je ne sais pas où élise la ligne
d'arrivée je ne vais pas même s'il ya
une ligne d'arrivée sans compter que
à moins d'une avarie majeure ou à moi de
ne pas en revenir on finit toujours par
faire le tour du monde
alors que le chemin
pour faire reconnaître l'océan comme un
bien commun de l'humanité au niveau des
nations unies ce chemin n'existe pas ya
pas deux continents à contourner pas de
cap horn pas de vent dominant tout est à
inventer
mais c'est étrange je sais au fond de
moi que ce chemin je dois le suivre sans
bien savoir où il va me mener
et peut-être que ce chemin je le suis
depuis toujours peut-être que tout ce
que j'ai accompli jusqu'à présent
me conduirait à mon insu vers ce but 6
20 et pourtant si grand
j'ai connu la mer en dessous avant de la
connaître au dessus quand j'étais enfant
nous passions de vacances entre les
calanques de marseille et la pointe de
la bretagne roscoff mon père nous et qui
paie mes frères ma soeur et moi de
combinaison de plongée de palmes masque
et tuba et nous partions à l'aventuré
avec les palmes à la main enfin deux
marées descendantes et nous attendions
d'avoir de l'eau au moins jusqu'aux
genoux pour pouvoir nous allonger et
nous nous progressions doucement avec
les les les algues coller aux masques
jusqu'à trouver suffisamment d'eau pour
pouvoir nager et puis un jour papa nos
amis à la plongée sous marine est
brutalement la mer est passé pour moi de
la deuxième à la troisième dimension il
y avait des collines il y avait des
canyon ça grouillait de vie bien
évidemment des poissons et les forêts et
les algues et les laminaires étaient
devenus des forêts que j'explorais c'est
à formidable sentiment j'ai compris ici
à c'est à ce moment là je le comprends
aujourd'hui que ma passion de la mer ndé
dans les laminaires de la pointe de la
bretagne fait ma première expérience
fondatrice
dans ces mêmes années j'ai compris que
non seulement elle était vivante mais
qu'elle était fragile en
1978 le naufrage de l'amoco cadiz a
entraîné une marée noire les plus
anciens parmi vous sent souvent
viendront une marée noire qui a atteint
les côtes de roscoff et j'ai des
souvenirs précis d'une photo aérienne on
voit arriver le front de boue qui a déjà
envahi le le port de roscoff et le fond
du port les n'a pas encore été atteint
les os sont encore trans suicide j'étais
horrifiée
à l'époque quand on rentrait de la plage
nous avions toujours du cambouis sous
nos chaussures et j'ignorais l'époque
c'est parce que les navires au large des
loyers leurs cuves de fuel avec l'eau de
mer depuis la réglementation a mis en
partie fin à ces pratiques du moins sur
nos côtes pas partout mais dans les
mêmes années il y avait déjà une autre
pollution qui déjà envahissent l océan
une pollution qu'on a mis pratiquement
plus de 40 ans à prendre la mesure
si la pollution des déchets qui vont à
la mer et cette pollution là moi je vais
la découvrir il ya 30 ans à l'occasion
de la première transat en solitaire
c'était la mini transat en 91 et alors
que je voyais déjà j'observais déjà des
déchets dans les fonds marins quand je
faisais de la plongée ou le long des
côtes quand je naviguais et là j'étais
en plein milieu de l'atlantique
et j'ai observé des pannes polystyrène
des bouteilles plastiques
ce n'était pas concevable à 1000 milles
de toute comptabilité de voir ces
déchets là et je ne me suis pas dit à ce
moment là où sont les affreux pollueurs
je me suis dit mais comment en est on
arrivé là collectivement je me suis
sentie responsable
j'ai senti cette responsabilité
individuelle et collective qui m'habite
encore aujourd'hui et j'ai su ce jour
qu'un jour il faudrait que j'agisse moi
même c'est ma deuxième expérience
fondatrice mais à ce moment-là j'ignore
quelles sont les solutions à à ma portée
et je poursuis la course au large
c'est l'expérience de mes deux tours du
monde en solitaire qui vont commencer à
me donner des clés facettes à ce
sentiment d'impuissance
vous l'avez compris le vendée globe
c'est une expérience de l'extrême quand
c'est bon c'est délicieusement bon quand
c'est dur c'est vraiment très dur on vit
des émotions particulièrement extrêmes
quand on est face à des avaries qui nous
semblent majeur et quand on est seul et
qu'on imagine qu'on sera incapable
de les réparer soi-même parce qu'on n'a
pas le choix parce qu'il en va de
l'intégrité du bateau et de notre propre
sécurité et bien trouve les solutions on
trouve les solutions c'est
extraordinaire pendant mon premier verre
de vendée globe une déferlante à à
bousculer mon bateau qui a mis la tête
de mât dans l'eau et heureusement le
bateau s'est redressé tout de suite
j'étais dans l'océan indien la tempête
est effroyable c'est celle qu'à
retourner les bateaux de raphaël dinelli
tomates d'ubs de tirer du bois et et
bullimore et heureusement ici redresser
tout de suite heureusement parce que
j'étais sur le pont jules temps juste de
m'accrocher au mas
sur le moment j'ai pas eu le temps
d'avoir peur
mais c'est après j'ai mis dix semaines à
m'en remettre des semaines où j'ai
bricolé réparer ranger et en particulier
j'ai réparé
une éolienne j'avais plus de groupes
électrogènes ils étaient tous morts les
deux j'en avais et sept éoliennes le
jour où je les réparer mais ça a été le
plus beau jour de votre vie pratiquement
parce que j'étais dans l'océan indien et
j'ai bouclé ce tour du monde depuis le
sang indien avec une éolienne et de
panneaux solaires
ce tour du monde face et deux tours du
monde parce que j'en ai faire derrière
m'ont donné des expériences des leçons
mais pour la vie pour la vie d'abord sur
mon propre potentiel
jeu pourquoi faut-il attendre d'être
dans des conditions extrêmes pour
explorer le potentiel que nous avons
vous avez un potentiel extraordinaire
n'attendez pas d'être dans des
conditions extrêmes pour les exploiter
ce potentiel
ça m'a donné aussi
vraiment là la conviction que l'être
humain est capable de résilience et puis
aussi ça m'a donné le 7 ce goût et cette
compréhension de la puissance du
collectif le bateau avec lequel j'ai
bouclé ce premier tour du monde en 80 16
81 97 23 mars 97 l'arrivée ces bateaux
je l'avais récupérer un mois et demi
avant le départ et il était parfaitement
préparée par l'équipe que j'avais réuni
au pied levé
la mère m'a aussi appris que on ne lutte
pas contre la mer contre les éléments
vous entendez toujours voulu tu voulais
marabout du thé contenant on ne lutte
pas on doit composer avec et cette leçon
en matière quand on parle des
conséquences du changement climatique et
de l'élévation du niveau de la mer on en
a entendu parler
eh bien ça ne sert à rien d'ériger des
remparts partout de construire des
digues peut-être à venise mais pas
partout il faut accepter l'immersion la
mer sera toujours plus forte
c'est tout du monde cette expérience
initiatrice des tours du monde
c'est ma troisième expérience vraiment
fondatrice en 2002 je décide d'arrêter
la course au large j'ai envie de
naviguer autrement j'ai envie d'être
utile de m'engager je reprends ma
casquette de journaliste et je décide de
montrer les solutions à une d'époque on
ne parle que des problèmes je veux m'ont
parlé de ses solutions dites durables
aujourd'hui on dirait et je pars aussi
dans des projets de deux bateaux
éco-conçus de voiliers du futur parce
que je veux entraîner la filière de type
qui est la mienne dans la transition
écologique je pense que j'étais un peu
pionnière et si certains projets ont
abouti le volet du futur n'a pas vu le
jour mais il aura inspiré je pense une
génération
le ministre de l'écologie de l'époque
qui entend parler de mes engagements de
propose d'abord une mission puis
m'entraîne dans l' aventure du grenelle
de la mer et là c'est l'apprentissage de
la réflexion collective la puissance du
collectif non au niveau de la réflexion
je découvre et je rencontre tous que la
france compte d' expertise sur la mer
les scientifiques les ong
le monde économique le monde social les
institutions ensemble nous faisons le
constat que la mer est l'avenir de la
terre et nous tentons d'en définir les
conditions de la durabilité et c'est sur
ce thème que je vais poursuivre au
conseil économique social
environnemental
où je vais décider de faire monter livre
de la mer sens figuré je vous rassure
dans cette institution qui semble
complètement ignoré les sujets et c'est
là que je vais vivre mon quatrième des
événements fondateurs
nous décidons d'organiser une conférence
internationale sur la gouvernance de la
haute mer la haute mer vous savez cette
zone au delà des des zones économiques
exclusives cette partie de l'océan
les fonds marins depuis la convention de
montego bay de 82 ont un statut
juridique mais la colonne d'eau au
dessus
n'a aucun statut juridique
or les explorations qu'on y fait montre
à mesure qu'on connaît mieux l'océan
mais qui a des richesses en matière de
biodiversité de ressources génétiques
sans parler des rochettes des richesses
minérales
et on voit bien l'appétit des uns et des
autres sur ces fonds donc il faut donner
un statut nous lançons l'appel de paris
pour la haute mer et dans cet appel
nous parlons de l'océan comme un bien
commun de l'humanité ça m'a été soufflée
par une amie sur le moment je prends pas
toute la dimension toute la mesure de la
richesse de cette de cette appellation
mais l'institut français de la mer
décide de créer un groupe de travail que
je rejoins et pendant plusieurs années
on va travailler sur le sur le sujet et
puis passez quelques mois quelques mois
plus tard avec le comité de pilotage
avec lequel nous avions organisé cette
conférence de via la plateforme motion
et climat qui encore aujourd'hui
continue de porter la voix de l'océan
dans les négociations climatiques de mon
côté à nouveau une ministre de l' de
l'environnement le propose d'embarquer
comme délégué à la mer littoral une
nouvelle mission que je mène pendant
deux ans formidables et je décide de la
quitter pour retrouver ma liberté de
parole m'adresser directement au chef de
l'état j'avais peur et lui demander un
portage politique de la mer au quotidien
parce que la mer on a besoin et moi je
décide de reprendre la mer parce qu'elle
me manque
au large je me demande mais comment
vais-je poursuivre mes engagements
d'ailleurs je croise des sargasses
y avait partout due au changement
climatique
comment poursuivre mes engagements
il faut absolument trouver un moyen
d'accélérer sur la conscientisation et
sur le passage à l'action parce que tout
le monde
est d'accord qu'il faut faire quelque
chose mais il faut accélérer et je veux
crier à l'humanité
que nous devons tous agir parce que
l'océan et touche il se réchauffe et ils
s'acidifient du fait de nos émissions de
co2 il étouffe de nos déchets de nos
pollutions contaminés je veux aussi dire
à l'humanité que l'océan est une
richesse
et pas uniquement parce que l'océan de
nouri et aussi la moitié de l'oxygène
que nous respirons etc l'océan est un
bien commun à toute l'humanité quel que
soit l'endroit où on habite même si on
est très éloignée des côtes on est tous
concernés par sa bonne santé
alors en rentrant de cette transat
je réunis les experts avec lesquels nous
vous avions démarré des travaux donc sur
le bien commun et ensemble nous décidons
de lancer l'appel pour l'océan indien
comme l humanité avec
l'ambition de la dgre et de le faire
intégrer dans le préambule du futur
traité sur la haute mer au passage
négociations en cours on pourrait avoir
un traité d'ici la fin de l'année et son
corollaire si l'océan est un bien commun
il est de notre responsabilité
individuelle et collective de le
préserver et donc on lance l'appel mais
il s'adresse aux états mais pas qu'aux
états vous l'avez compris il s'adresse
aussi aux collectivités aux entreprises
aux citoyens et cet appel est
véritablement mon cinquième événement
fondateur nous le lançons les 8 juin
2018 avec les coureurs du vendée globe
et
et puis nous partons nous nous engageons
pendant plusieurs années à essayer de de
le promouvoir nous organisons des
événements des conférences avec
françoise gaill le scénographe qui
m'accompagne eudes riblier là le
président de l'institut français de la
mer nous organisons aussi des séminaires
nous invitons des sociologues des
philosophes des anthropologues pour
essayer d'explorer ce ce concept parce
qu'il faut comprendre s'il exige qu'il
yad'autres concept qui existe à travers
le monde en fait nous réalisons que nous
inventons un concept parce que le bien
commun nous le qualifions pas uniquement
pour les poissons pour les ressources
génétiques pour tous que l'océan apporte
comme bienfaits l'humanité mais pour
l'intégralité de l'océan au regard des
bienfaits qu'ils apportent à l'humanité
alors tout ça ça doit vous paraître un
peu stratosphérique comment mon bien
commun peut changer les comportements
mais c'est au nom du bien commun qu'il
nous faut fermer le robinet des déchets
qui vont à la mer c'est au nom du bien
commun qu'il faut réduire nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre c'est au nom du
bien commun qu'il faut aller préserver
l'arctique et l'antarctique
c'est au nom du bien commun qu'il faut
partager les données que les
scientifiques collecte et c'est au nom
du bien commun que nous devons tous
participer vous moi à la régénération de
l'océan
régénérer l'océan c'est du reste
l'initiative que nous avons lancé avec
les jeunes qui nous accompagnent dans
cette belle initiative
sur un territoire du morbihan qui
s'appelle aurait quiberon et atlantique
nous avons lancé le projet blue print
ce territoire est structurée par trois
bassins versants tous les trois pollué
devons tous les trois à la mer ç'a un
impact pour les ostréiculteurs
et ça nous intéresse pas de savoir où
sont les offres pollueurs là encore ce
qui nous intéresse c'est que chacun
comprenne qu'il a sa part à faire et
donc il nous faut valoriser les bonnes
pratiques donnés à d'autres l'envié
d'agir est engagée la spirale vertueuse
on a lancé ce projet l'année dernière en
juin de l'année dernière
et ça marche ça prend blueprint prend il
ne cherche pas à se substituer ce projet
aux politiques publiques justes à les
accélérer parce qu'on a des politiques
publiques qui s'occupe de prendre soin
de l'océan des plus politiques
européennes et d'ailleurs j'ai pris mon
mandat européen avec l'ambition après
l'avoir refusé trois fois avec
l'ambition justement de porter le bien
commun aussi au niveau européen
notamment depuis que la france le
soutien
alors avec le projet blue print je
retrouve le plaisir d'être dans des
projets concrets de terrain du local au
global
en fait je sens que j'ai besoin d'agir à
ces deux échelons et que ces deux
échelons au besoin de dialoguer entre
deux de s'inspirer mutuellement
au delà du
l'objectif qui est le nôtre encore une
fois je suis épaté par la puissance du
collectif et elle me fait croire que
nous sommes en capacité de relever le
défi des enjeux climatiques
et de biodiversité devant lesquels ne
sont alors quatre ans après avoir lancé
cet appel pour l'océan bien commun de
l'humanité
eh bien il n'a jamais la notion n'a
jamais été autant porter au niveau
français mais aussi au niveau
international il paraîtrait même qu'elle
est acquise mais dit on depuis le wan ho
chi minh qui avait dû à brest en février
où on a réussi des airs à stabiliser sa
traduction en anglais ce n'était pas
facile via xianda the global commeinhes
et mais moi je veux le voir écrit noir
sur blanc dans le préambule d'un traité
international on ne veut pas en faire un
une notion juridique
c'est une notion morale donc il ne
devrait pas être si compliqué de le
faire intégrer alors des notions soeur
je lis un peu dit émergent partout à
travers le monde il ya même des gens qui
voudraient que l'eau science va reconnue
comme une personnalité juridique
déjà des rivières leçons
alors comme les idées émergent un peu
partout à travers le monde
j'ai envie de citer victor hugo qui est
j'adore cette phrase rien n'est plus
puissant qu'une idée dont le temps est
venu
eh bien rien n'est plus puissant le
temps de l'océan bien commun de
l'humanité est venue
alors je ne sais pas où tout ça va me
mener je vous la vous et parfois je me
demande même si la quête que je poursuis
n'est pas tout aussi essentiel que
l'objectif que je recherche
et cette quête
cette quête je le sais me passera à
nouveau par la mer par l'océan dans
quelques mois je reprendrai la mer
[Applaudissements]